same time so it's a great combination I
enjoyed I enjoyed it yeah I'm sure you
did it sounds fantastic thank you so
much for joining us I think
hyrum is gonna come in and join us yeah
I was coming in he's coming in yeah oh
wait can you do the one eyebrow raise
like the rock I'll do my best
there's there's bitter and the family
the mind but yeah absolutely really
really good cuz I can't do it at all
wait I'm gonna try hold on no it's not
working
hello how you doing good to see good to
see you we're here Hobbs and Shaw cliff
Curtis I mean this is a dream come on
this is a dream tell me though how big a
dream is it you have known the rock
since you guys were kids from the very
beginning to you know all the steps
you've taken along the way how is this
one different what does it mean to you
well I mean look anytime you can as
cliff will tell you making movies is
hard and anytime you can make a movie
it's a win but the idea for this
actually started back in 2010 we've been
working and focused on this when we
created the character of Hobbs so to be
here now middle of Hollywood all these
fans everything's come together you know
it's so exciting we're just so humbled
to be able to pull it off and now we
have this movie that we're so confident
in it's fun it's big pays homage to The
Fast and Furious universe builds it out
in a great way while introducing great
new characters like cliff
Idris Vanessa a zig and Hollis I mean it
is it's a big fun world and we're so
thrilled to unleash it to the universe
and let let all the fans have some more
fun and your production company seven
box production was involved in this you
personally what was important to you
because I know it's a fast and furious
movie but this is kicking off a whole
new franchise everybody really wanted
this this is something that fans have
been waiting for and wanting for a long
time what was most important to you that
you showcase in this film
well like I think for us we wanted to
ultimately we wanted to be able to
support the Fast and Furious universe
this is a spin-off this is all about
supporting the mothership but also
creating something that's worthy of fans
coming out coming to the theaters it's
hard to get people to the theaters
movies are expensive so we take great
pride - seven bucks and creating
theatrical events events that you come
have funds with the audience laughs see
the explosions see the set pieces
family heart ass-kicking seva towels you
name it I mean it's it's that's we
wanted to do was make an event that
people came to the theater and they said
god this was worth it I want more of
this please just keep giving us more of
it and I think we were able to do that I
think it's really funny is that fans
always kid like well fast and furious
ever go into outer space and it feels
like we're close to the Sun today
because it is so crazy hot you guys look
great despite the heat I'm trying to
keep it together but listen anything's
possible
with fast and furious space Santa Claus
who knows but of if it's possible we'll
go for it I need to know did you learn
this Eva towel I watched I memorize it
in my head but there's some things that
you just don't want I would have messed
it up these guys and you got to see him
with the most incredible incredible so
yeah I watch from afar well thank you
both I'm gonna relieve you I know you've
been standing here for a while now
thank you both congratulations this is
so exciting and I'm gonna toss it back
to Roman thanks again guys
everyone arriving right now looking
fabulous and of course this movie Hobson
sure well it features two very different
guys to be totally honest right there
card Shaw Luke Hobbs I mean they're not
exactly friends I mean they were enemies
but we like to call them the breasts of
frenemies take a look
you think I'm stupid of course I think
you're stupid but you know what I'll do
you a favor I'm not that dumb right out
of your skull you just say the word Jack
it was on set a fast date that there was
a unique chemistry that just started to
build between myself and Jason hubs and
show you no I want to kill each other
this time we have to come together as a
team of two even though they hate each
other and at each other's throats there
is a common respect between the two we
are so different and yet we're so
similar the chemistry between Dwayne and
Jason it's pretty special and it's hard
to find that look
Slithe time to have the opportunity to
take these guys and build a world around
of that chemistry it was really exciting
to you I just dread they killed you
before I woke up pretty disappointed
right now alright I've known Jason now
for a very long time and I take great
joy in making him laugh while the
cameras are rolling it brings me so much
joy we know how to be also-ran that's
the boy excited thick
I love it yeah that's gonna be good
see I told you the best of frenemies
right as you can see arriving right now
looking absolutely stunning Vanessa
Kirby she is here right there with mr.
david leitch now of vanessa in this
movie all I can tell you is that she is
an absolute boss
she owns every single part of this okay
as happy sure of course and they team up
it is phenomenal but vanessa is going to
be here obviously being part of the fast
franchise I mean it doesn't get any
bigger than that and also in this movie
having Helen Mirren as of mother is is
quite big as well isn't it I mean Helen
made that parrot Helen Mirren's your mum
and then Jason Statham is your brother
now we're going to make sure that we get
a little bit of a family chat here today
but as I say all the stars arriving
today we couldn't see mr. Jason Statham
right there
oddly dressed all in black which based
on the heat today we are basically on
the surface of the Sun it is that hot
maybe it was a different choice and
there the main man himself mr. Dwayne
Johnson both for those guys
arriving not too far apart taking photos
with the crowd absolutely loving it this
is a big moment of course for Dwayne
Johnson for the rock for Jason Statham
as well seeing their characters pitting
lights Fast and the Furious presents
Hobbs and sure
what a guy the greatest action movie
hero of all time who knows it's a big
call he might just be doing it taking
pitches with the crowd of course
[Applause]
idris elba arriving earlier on straight
to the fans this is the first time a
dress has become part of the fast
franchise as well taking on the role of
Brixton law what role indeed as well a
superhuman I mean he does look like a
superhuman normally but this time he
actually gets to say is it race has
actually tried to do this I mean taking
time out from DJing around the world as
well being featured on records around
the world as well wrapping everything
the man has too many talents that's the
problem he might actually be superhuman
now that I've said that
idris elba jason statham looking dapper
representing of course the shore science
today I love the fat but address elbow
is part of a fast franchise movie he is
just the perfect villain he looks cool
he's got the swag and he's basically a
modern Terminator it's unbelievable so
many fans outside queueing wanting to
get their photos with the stars and the
stars well they're living up to their
promise as well they're going right the
way down Hollywood Boulevard today
everyone arriving in style taking photos
signing autographs just goes to show why
this really is the biggest biggest
franchise and set of movies ever this
technically being the 9th in the Fast &
Furious franchise
[Music]
as we see the snails approaching as well
everyone making their way in to the
theater ready right here at the fast and
furious present Hobbs and Shore world
premiere or as you like to call it in
America a premiere we're yet to see the
champagne flowing here on the shore side
though there is a problem
[Music]
I'm joined by the wonderful Vanessa
Kirby Vanessa how are you today I'm
really good but listen I mean being here
today I mean we are representing England
we're representing I mean London town
right now well we've got Big Ben and
we've got Westminster Abbey
what did that yeah they didn't install
the rain machine engine it has invaded
the franchise now being a part of it
being a part of the fast franchise what
does it mean to you getting involved in
a movie like this well I mean it's that
British thing I thing with Idris and
Helen and like it was really cool we
filmed in London for you know three
months and it's I think it was the I'm
really proud to bring a bit of Britain
to it
you are an absolute boss in this movie
you've got but this is the thing you've
got yes this is the thing I mean you've
got Jason Statham in they've got dwayne
johnson you've got a dress elbow you
know all of them they can handle their
own but I mean being a part of this and
really going for it what was it like
filming filming this and just going
through your paces I just really wanted
to make sure that the female character
in it was as big of his boss as those
guys because they're really cool so
every moment and I'm not very cool so I
got to be cool for like a few months but
yeah I just really wanted to take care
of like how capable she was and that she
was just as strong as them and she was
able to fight all her own battles by
herself and not be saved by them and you
know and they were amazing and like
little spoiler like Dwayne lets me beat
him up as well in this film are you
getting injuries knows I'm so a key I
could barely walk most days and like I
am not naturally a sports person I was
always lasted than running weights at
school so I was like terrified but Greg
the fight director is incredible and
just made me feel okay and he taught
charli's on an atomic blonde so I was
like if I could even be like 1% about
cool she was and capable then maybe are
like survivor yeah a little bit I mean
this this being you know a project for
you we've seen you just go in bigger
projects bigger bigger bigger how does
this differ like from the other stuff
that obviously you've been a part of
probably the scale you know like I'm a
theater girl I came from like just doing
years of theater so suddenly being in
Hawaii on this cliff edge with Dwayne
and a helicopter lately she's circling
around us as we have this little this
little moment was like really surreal
halfway through the scene I was like
what the hell is going on like why am I
not in London say yeah it was yeah the
scale of it I think I heard as well but
they have a traveling gym just for
Dwayne I tried to break into a couple of
times
what's the traveling to marking I was
like I need to practice my running cuz
I'm like super unfit and I tried to go
into it but it's I think is exclusively
these two DJ yeah traveling to oomiya
traveling to I think his meditation you
know it's his therapy like he just and
you know taught us a lot about
discipline and you know there's a lot of
testosterone on this set the flexing
must have been incredible who was trying
to flex the most I would say it was
honestly it was a dead equal amount of
flexing but I had Kelly McCormack was
the producer who's David's wife and so
we were like the women on set like
really representing yeah now now let's
talk about it we saw you earlier on
talking about David Leitch you mentioned
in there now you said you had a mantra
in David Leitch We Trust why what is
this why he's just not only is the
nicest man on earth and like the most
charismatic and wonderful but he's just
a proper filmmaker you know like and you
really feel that on set like such a
visual artist but like he's a true
artist and I think it's amazing that
he's bringing his own take to the
franchise and I think I haven't seen it
and you have but I know that it will
have like a David Leitch it'll be like a
David Lee's movie and I've always wanted
to do one with him and it was like a
true honor and he was everything that he
you know he lived up to everything that
I'd heard about him amazing well listen
it is so great to have you a part of
this here today as well can I just say
for everyone else that's watching well
this is the thick and can you just bow
for me because it is so hot that we're
not used to this saying and also I cut
my I cut my knee on
on when I was shaving my legs just
before I left so I'm like I've got a
wound got a war wound really bad I was
right exactly well listen thank you so
much for stopping today let's go back to
the other side what's going on with you
Nikki
oh you know just having some fun over
here you know one thing you know when
it's a fast and furious movie and you
can see by the carpet today is that
everybody is stunning
and they are so bringing it to this road
carpet today I want to just sort of like
go back and have a few looks at you know
what we're seeing today here on the road
carpet all right so first of all when
Dwayne came in and Jason came Ben they
looked so slick they look cool but then
Vanessa showed up and I'm sorry slaying
her she just stole my heart she stole my
heart from the second she walked on the
carpet she looks incredible
I've also seen a second's Ollis we're
gonna talk to her in a little bit but
let's just have a look here down on the
carpet at what we're seeing and some of
the fashion that we're seeing today at
the Hobson shop premiere well you can
see right now the cars are bringing it
I'll tell you that much the cars are
amazing okay that one I think I'm gonna
take for a little roll after that after
the premiere it's over but it's been it
is hot but I will say you can't even
tell oh no I changed my mind I think
I'll be rolling out in that one not sure
who with I think Vanessa I think I want
to leave it for that I think Vanessa and
I need to go and hit the town after this
but you know this is one of the most
hotly anticipated movies fans have been
waiting for this they want to know what
the Hobbs and Shaw spin-off is gonna be
like it's part of the Fast & Furious
franchise but we know they're gonna
bring their own style and their own
speed to it and I think this is one of
the coolest carpets I've ever seen I
mean having the road having you know the
fans the fan pit the interaction and I
gotta say as much as I like Roman camp I
kind of like holding court over here on
the hop side it's it's not bad it's
lot of fun so you know just so much
excitement and what was cool is that
Jason and the rock really kicked off
this whole thing sometimes we wait for
the stars to arrive they come towards
the end but they really rolled in and
kicked off the energy to this whole
event okay I can hear the fans are now
cheering for the rock it's it's
pandemonium down here it's crazy it's a
lot of fun I think we're gonna talk to a
Segen solace and a couple of minutes she
is a new addition to the cast and she's
been I can tell you she has been owning
it she was a huge fan of the franchise
to begin with so I can't wait to talk to
her and find out you know what it was
like to be part of this whole thing but
right now I am tossing it back to Roman
Roman I think you got a special guest
there with the main man himself deck
hard sure Jason Statham hello sir how
are we it's nice isn't it bringing a
little bit of London here today to
Hollywood we brought a little bit of it
yeah you should look you're refering to
the car I'd presume of course
sorry generated McLaren now turning up
arriving in style that was a pretty nice
moment wasn't it
you know what we've thought should we
have the Peterbilt truck or should we
have the McLaren with the old slick
motor now talk to me about this film
it's finally happened Hobbs in sure name
in lights were you just absolutely
itching to get into this you know what
we've done a couple of films from in the
first universe before and we really
enjoy giving each other a lot of stick
and we thought you know what if we can
just do a little bit more of that and
have a good time doing it why not we
spoke earlier on to Vanessa and
obviously you know you Idris Dwayne
there but Vanessa brings it in this
movie doesn't she she's rather good yeah
she does a great job and of course
seeing Dame Helen Mirren as your mum how
does how does that kind of work is it a
little bit nerve-racking you know what
she makes it the easiest day of all the
days that we
on set she's the easiest because she
just comes and just she knows every
little bit of what she needs to do and
then she goes home she's a sweetheart
she's super loving and friendly toward a
crew she's just you know one of the
Great's or one of the great greats and
you know you can just you feel the you
feel everything that she's giving out
and yet for me we had like and you know
a day two days it was one single day
yeah rather special and of course how do
you think no for those fast and furious
fans of the franchise how does this
differ from from those movies what does
a lot of people that aren't in it you
know this is one of the things that uh
that we were quite nervous about because
we want to be respectful to the first
universe and everybody that is part of
that and I mean I just came in as a
small part in the early you know in the
part 5 the end and then those six then
seven and eight so you know I'm very
cautious about these types of films and
what they can do and the messages that
they can send but you know I I'm not the
one who makes decisions and I'm not the
one who creates ideas but you know I'd
be silly to say no to this type of an
offer but you know we we could never
take our eye off what is the DNA of the
you know the deviced universe so we've
been very cautious and treaded very
tried very carefully to keep that as a
special place so you know here we are
it's just a couple of chaps that have
been extracted out of the the fast world
and sent on a little ride well listen
finally I have to mention it you're
taking on Brits the law idris elba what
was it like coming up against the dress
in this movie well he's about as good as
you can get in terms of a super villain
yeah I've had a massive respect for
Regis you know I've known him for many
many years outside of the professional
world that we both live in and I know a
Barry's kickbox in an hour about his
fighting skills so when you give someone
with that authentic sort of a skill
a great sort of moment SACEUR kicked the
crap outta me and Dwayne you believe it
yes it's great
I mean Aegis is really excelled and you
know the work he does is it speaks for
itself so he is truly someone I've been
wanting to work with for many many years
it's a fantastic movie congratulations
thank you so much thank you thank you
you didn't swear he didn't he said he
promised me honestly Nicky I told him
you told him you told him oh my gosh how
amazing does he look he looks in he
looks in faretta ball and he's talking
to the young star that plays up the
rocks daughter in the film we can see
Jason and of course with Rosie looking
absolutely
Gordon if I can talk saying those to her
they should be separate on the carpet
it's too much hot it's just too much pot
for this carpet we need we need Rosie to
come down to this end to the hob side
bail though she probably won't oh we
finally took its glasses off amazing
this is what we want we want to see his
eyes yes don't we fans we definitely
want to see him wow talk about slaying
talk about stunning on the carpet and
they look cool Carmen glad you don't
they it must be the British thing they
just don't get warm what is it
Wow amazing amazing can we cast her in
the next Furious movie I think we should
I think we should cast her in the next
movie we're doing it right now so we've
seen every major star arrive here on the
carpet and I can just tell you the
energy here is so high the two of them
Wow dream a Hollywood couple incredible
you can see fans are lined up all down
the boulevard this is just you know this
is a huge event I mean there's there's
premieres in Hollywood but this is a
premiere of premieres this is one that
people have been waiting for people have
been here since early today waiting they
want to see the rock they want to see
Jason Statham they want to see a Juris
Elba
they want to see Vanessa Kirby I mean
just such a stellar cast in this movie
of course you can always expect that
from The Fast and Furious franchise so
but this Hobbs and shots the first time
they've got their own spin-off we can't
wait to see what kind of spin they put
on this film people keep coming in
they're just pouring in and you know
everybody's just excited there's just a
feeling in the air of excitement and
energy part of it is the way that they
came rolling in I mean that just really
kicked things off and it's really
awesome having a such a big stretch of
this road we've got like two sides
through the carpet happening never
happened before but I've got to tell you
it's definitely weird it's definitely
working we're having fun down here on
this end the fans are excited I can tell
you they all have their phones out there
already because I'm seeing the rock is
going to be coming down here very
shortly
yeah people are chanting for him they're
calling him Bronte wrong guy but I get
it get it I'm not mad at you
yeah I mean what excitement there's for
you there are very few stars they can
bring out this type of a crowd and
Dwayne Johnson is definitely one of them
arguably one of the biggest if not the
biggest star in the world and you know
just look at his Instagram following I
know I do daily 150 million followers
something like that
and we can see him down there on the
carpet locating incredible okay even the
Rockettes warm okay I feel better he's
he's human he is human well yes but
posing for pictures the rock I can tell
you because I've interviewed him before
I've talked to him before he is the guy
and everybody says he's nice but he
stops for everyone he really does he
talks to every single person he always
spends time with his fans and you know
what that face time that one-on-one time
it's really special for people and it's
just really wonderful that he takes the
time and does it because even though we
we wait and we wait and we wait to talk
to him it's it's why everybody loves the
rock is that as larger-than-life as he
is on the screen he's just this personal
personable guy in person so warm
and and I think anytime he gets involved
in a project there's just this positive
error positive feel in the air and you
can see everybody's just students
swarming him cameras I wonder if he's
used to it I wonder if he I'm sure he's
used to it by now but I just
I wonder but you know looking looking
great I really liked the shirt open the
whole look he might as well go with the
weather go go with what's happening but
yeah wow what a moment here
all right I think we are gonna go over
Roman very shortly actually right now
here we go
Romilly take it away thank you very much
Nicky I am joined by mr. Chris Morgan
writer extraordinaire in the Fast
franchise Chris told to me about this
movie how excited are you that finally
people are getting to see it have you
looked at the crowds out here yet it is
pretty incredible it's one thing when
you're sitting in your at your computer
at a coffee shop and kind of clinking
keys and then you look at this like it
is amazing it's amazing I'm so thankful
how do you even go about starting on a
film like this because you know that I
was speaking to David Leitch and to
Kelly as well wanting to make it
different to the rest of the fast
franchise how did you put your touch on
that I think it is less than it being
different it's more of them with the
regular fast films we have such a giant
ensemble that you don't have a lot of
time to delve into the characters and
their backstories and what they hope for
and who their families are so the idea
of a spinoff was hoping to be able to
take two characters and really get to
drill down and get to know a little bit
more about them and I think you know
with Universal and all our fast partners
we've been looking to do that for awhile
when we were on the set of fast eight
and we have a sequence where it's Dwayne
and Jason and prison cells and they are
insulting each other back and forth I
will tell you at the end of the day
there we're sitting there and like all
our grips and electrics when those guys
who have been lugging cable and stuff
all day long and they're exhausted and
they're laughing I went home with my
cheeks hurting because of just the
banter between those two guys we knew
we're like that's it this is it exactly
and I mean taking on a project that has
a dress elbow as a superhuman man alive
right now and now he's a bionic sexiest
man alive I mean was it an easy decision
just the Oh a dress perfect Idris
perfect for a lot of reasons one is he's
a friend so yes we've been looking to
get him in the fast franchise for a very
long time and also we knew we were gonna
have a heightened sort of story here so
we wanted someone an actor who could
ground it like really bring a
professionalism and just kill it
that
is a drizelda 100% so we got really
lucky and I will say this part of the
reason for the kind of genetics
super-soldier is we have two of the
biggest alpha action stars in the world
that he has to go up against we just
wanted to make sure we gave him a little
something to give them an extra
beat-down look a little bit unfair it's
like you've got to come up against Jason
Statham and Dwayne Johnson puts them
down oh yes we made sure now working
with Dwayne as well you know everyone
that you speak to just says he's the
best bloke in the world he's the best
guy I mean does he does he really live
up to that I'm gonna be the most
repetitive dude in the world he is and I
can tell you I will just say this I
remember on Fast Five when we brought
him in we specifically wrote the role
for him and went and courted him like
please come in he came in and we had a
great time with it I remember the
premiere that the red carpet everyone
comes in dust photos and we do all these
things
Dwayne came in did all this then jumped
over the barrier and went in with the
fans and the second I saw that I'm like
that guy is special there's something
special even on this set between takes
he will bring in kids from the
make-a-wish Foundation to to do just
beautiful things to help people he is
genuinely one of the best human beings
I've ever met in my life and I am odd
being around him now my my other part of
me is asking for spoilers on Fast 9
thank you so much man thank you thank
you Chris Nikki back to you don't make
it weird I'm sorry I know you're having
fun over there but I just won we won
because I am here with a rock great to
see you we won we won we it's good to
see you too it's so good to be here and
you know what an entrance I think for
all of us and you come out and there's
thousands of fans here and they're
chanting my name and everybody else's
name it's really really cool okay you're
downplaying it that entrance in that
truck was insane I think that's the
coolest entrance I've ever seen at a
premiere in my entire life you can
repeat that again so coolest entrance I
mean I just have one question you look
amazing I like the whole look where's
the lava lava that you wear during the
submission this is Ralph Lauren
custom-made Thank You Ralph and also the
lava I'm wearing it underneath okay so
for people who don't know what that is
lava lava is a Samoan wraparound it's
kind of like like women wear songs but
men wear it too and I have it on
underneath the pants you just made it
weird
I did I just do that it just happened
now I can't even think of my next
question here's my next question we have
dual into the carpet so I'm gonna ask
you a dual question first of all fans of
fast and furious and now your first
spin-off Hobson Shaw they are wait
they've been waiting for so long so just
give me give them a little tease for
what to expect in terms of the action
but then on the other side I just saw
you're here with your mom yes I know it
was very important to you to represent
the Samoan culture in this film so the
heart of the film and the Brawn of the
film okay well let's start with the
first question is you know the faster
viewers friends have been not only so
loyal but also just so excited about the
spin-off we've been talking about doing
a spin-off since fast six just trying to
figure out the right creative and the
fans all along as always by the way
which all the cast's in Hobbes and Shaw
and in the Fast and Furious movies can
all attest to the fans loyalty and their
excitement for something cool and
something fresh and new and different
and we wanted to deliver it obviously
it's a very critical
because it's very critical it's it's
after eight fast and furious movies we
all decided that we're gonna spin this
off and create Hobbes and Shaw so I'm
very excited and I think we made
something special and for all the fans
out there because we are live and you
can't take this back this microphone is
live I think we delivered a great movie
all the fans who have already seen it
have been loving the movie and and
loving a few of the surprises that
you'll see in the movie a few of the
surprises everybody wants to know what
the surprises are because every wants to
know who the guests are gonna be well
the special guests are friends of mine
and they became friends of our casts and
also you know the idea was to create new
characters and fun characters and to
build out the Fast and Furious franchise
and again just bring in these new faces
and faces that audiences around the
world love and and and build out
Hobbes's team got to build it out keep
building it I know I got to let you go
it was wonderful to see you wish you
could keep you keep you here all day I'm
I'd win anyway Mike win review what we
all win we all with this great look you
have we all but I will say this thank
you for bringing up the Samoa part
because it was so important to us to
showcase both our culture's Jason's
British culture and my Samoan culture
I'm half black and half someone so to be
able to showcase one of my cultures
which we've talked about this in the
past was deeply personal to me so I'm
excited for fans to see it and for the
first time ever in cinematic history
it's a very first time that someone
culture has been showcased on a big
scale like this so it's pretty cool and
I'm very excited fans are excited we're
excited thank you so much for dropping
by and congratulations thank you so much
for this enjoy the night here we are
Hobbs and Shawn world premiere day made
that's just the way it goes when you
interview the rock as you can see the
sweetest most personal guy and he talked
a lot about you know like we expect from
Fast & Furious franchise LeBron the
action scenes which we know in david
leitch we trust because he brings a like
nobody else but also the heart of the
film and that's what really fast and
furious is known for
[Applause]
and he brought not only his culture into
the film his family members his husband
Roman reigns is in this film but he
really represents a sense of family in
this film the Samoan scenes look off the
chain I know when the trailer dropped
people were just going crazy see there
he goes again just making Wednesday but
that's you know that's sort of what he
does and that's what he brings to every
film that he creates everything that he
touches he puts his heart and soul into
it you can see he's he's down on the
carpet he is talking to fans he is going
he's basically you know being the rock
he's doing what he does and that is
signing every single autograph and
talking to every single person okay you
guys as we know on set sometimes things
always don't go according to plan the
best plate laid plans you know how that
goes especially when there's a lot of
stunts involved so there was a really
really fun moment wasn't fun in first
but end up being funny behind the scenes
with Roman reigns just have a look at
this I turn around and I hear oh my god
we are rehearsing this scene and it's a
big scene where both of us are supposed
to take our clubs over our heads throw
who they say okay guys a lot of people
around no need to throw the club got it
Joe got
brother no need to throw the club I
pretend to throw my club and I hear oh
my god I turn around the [ __ ]
cameraman is knocked out come find out
Joe's like oh the club but everyone just
looks at me even me I like to move it he
felt so bad I haven't stopped
apologizing about camera I'm just like
oh no I'm okay teeth I'm okay I'm okay
he is a champ he took it he bounced
right back up he was not mad at me we
hugged it out but I still feel terrible
[Applause]
alright here we are on the carpet for
Hobbes and Shaw and I have with me the
stunning and she is oh my gosh I can't
even tell you this she is bringing it
today
asa gonzalez great to see you how are
you I'm doing well how are you good now
I know you are a huge fan of this
franchise growing up tell me a little
bit about I mean it's unbelievable to
see that weird today in this stage you
know I totally grew up with the Fast &
Furious franchise I have a brother who's
14 years older than me so it was all
about fast cars and beautiful ladies and
it's so nice to be working with this
incredible cast and crew and our
director who did it such a good job and
you know it's exciting to be portraying
a Latino and in in this world because
it's been so iconic for the Latin
community so sort of be part of one of
those ladies in this world and there are
so badass I mean every single and from
every age you know you have Helen Mirren
and Vanessa curvy and Michelle and
Jordan like everyone in it has been so
talented and so cool that I'm just
honored to be here okay but you bring it
bringing it you are bringing it I want
to know because you're going to toe to
toe with all these characters he's
larger-than-life personalities and
actors what is your sort of like do you
have like a pre scene ritual to sort of
get in the zone when you're in your
trailer like what's your process yeah I
think that to me what really works is
get to know them and if I can hang out
and talk to them before and so feel
comfortable with my surroundings because
it's also scary you know you come to
this new setting you really don't know
all these personalities you don't know
if you're gonna get along with each
other and it's always sort of like the
first day of school then it's also not
cool when the whole school has been
going on for like a whole year and it's
middle of the year and you're like hi
which is kind of what happened with me
because I was dropping from one film to
the other but everyone was so nice to me
it is so welcoming and it was nice and I
also got like my little blessing from
Vin Diesel because I had just done a
movie with him so it was
nice it was a very full circle thing for
me and I you know I had this whole
conversation with him was like I want a
really honor the franchise and everyone
when I got there was just so warm and
sweet to me so I loved it and it was it
was great so I heard after talking
earlier there's a lot of testosterone
unsaid you two females are representing
I think she said something like the rock
lets her beat him up or something like
that did you get the same privilege I am
quick with words and I'm sort of very
condescendingly nice sometimes with them
just with them so I would give them I
would give them remind them that women
sometimes are the stronger the stronger
sex but you know there's so much
testosterone but Vanessa brought it I
will tell you she brought it and wait
till you see her in this film she's
absolutely incredible and everyone sort
of did such an incredible job I wish I
had the strength to punch either one of
them I think I would break my hand if I
tried so I had to stayed away but I use
my quick words to kind of make them
nervous well great to talk to you you
look absolutely gorgeous you slay in
this movie congratulations can't wait to
see a female lead fast and furious movie
and I'm gonna toss it over to Roman with
that thought so as you can see I'm
joined and to be honest right Jason
Statham Dwayne Johnson being in this
movie as well I can comfortably say that
the coolest person is here it is Elba
you weren't set out to their faces would
ya course not
course I wouldn't I've said it's all of
you interest of course I have now you're
finally here you're finally part of a
fast franchise movie how did this how
did this come about how happy are you
I'm ecstatic if I'm honest like honestly
David liters the was the swing for me
like he's a million director great
vision and I wanted to work of him I
also wanted to work with Jason and
Dwayne but this little package is like
probably the best sort of dream jobs you
know and I mean like incredible like
attention to the to the to the action
and a little sense of humor as well it's
like it's good laugh really good it's a
perfect thing for you I mean you called
it a good laugh but may you get to walk
on
being a superhuman now that you've
coined the phrase the black Superman as
well I try absolutely love I mean what
was it like taking on a character like
this it was amazing actually from an
actor's point of view it's a dream
because he's like part machine part
human and the complexities of all of
that really I had to play that but also
I get to you know kick Duane to us and
kick Jason I mean both of them boys get
it you know I mean so what else could
ask for it was good good good times
of course now my final question has to
be right
you'd making action movies you know
you're turning up left right and center
but you're also you're DJing around the
world you're on a huge record around the
world how do you find the time you know
I'll sleep when I'm dead that's the only
thing I can tell you right now man like
it's about you know teamwork I don't do
it all by myself oh great team and we
just sort of dream it up and go do it
I mean it's fantastic listen
congratulations power could be happier
for you thank you very much Adria selva
signing out here at the Hogs and Shaw
world premiere I mean Nikki I know
you've had some pretty cool people but
yeah and then some I mean it's been so
much fun down here so much energy I know
you had a lot of fun too you've just got
that British banter that woody thing
happening but we still bring it we keep
it real down here you know we got our
trucks and our motorcycles and the whole
thing did you a good time the thing is
is the in England and in general in the
UK we have to try and find a sense of
humor because otherwise it's just
raining all the time and that's a bit
it's a bit rubbish our lives are just
great here all the time
I'm shine every day everything's great
you know we basically walked down the
street in slow-mo we do it I did think
so everyone was walking quite slowly so
this is it this is the ending ready
we're gonna have to see each other again
at the sequel you guys thank you so much
for tuning into this live stream we hope
you enjoyed it and felt like you were
right
here with the fans with the rock with
Jason with a dress and with Roman and
myself thank you all for joining us
thanks for staying with us the whole
time can't wait for you guys to go out
and see this movie we're gonna go party
see the film you know yeah for joining
us good night everybody
[Music]
you
you